in the 19th century with Maxwell's
synthesis of the laws of electricity and
magnetism physicists started to realize
that what we perceive as light is deeply
understood as a kind of disturbance and
electromagnetic electric and magnetic
fields that gave us a new concept of the
possibilities of perception of light
that show us that we're missing a lot
the electromagnetic equations permit
radiation of any wavelength and of any
frequency what we perceive as color what
we perceive as as light is corresponds
to a very narrow band of frequencies out
of an infinite continuum not only that
but even within that band we take 3
averages we don't sample all the
different frequencies but just 3
averages
that's called tri-chromatic vision so
for instance in computer displays there
are 3 different kinds of lighting
elements used when you see on your menu
the choice of millions of different
colors that doesn't mean different
lighting arrangements and lighting
possibilities it means different
combinations different relative
intensities of just 3 any perceived
color can be synthesized from three
basic colors other creatures see less
dogs for instance see only two kinds of
colors like colorblind people see
basically only two kinds of colors other
creatures see more other creatures many
insects and birds see four or five
colors they also sample kinds of light
kinds of electromagnetic radiation that
humans don't see
there's infrared radiation there's
ultraviolet radiation Maxwell's
equations which describe light also
describe radio waves and microwaves and
x-rays and gamma-rays so all those
things are possible forms of vision that
human natural endowment doesn't tap into
but it's out there on the one hand it's
very important to make concepts visual
because it taps into very powerful
methods of processing that we have and
on the other hand scientific knowledge
of what light is shows us that our
natural perception leaves a lot on the
table and so it leaves us with the
program of doing better with telescopes
microscopes spectrometers and other
kinds of gadgets that I'm developing for
everyday life that'll allow us to see
more colors the human perception of
color is limited really by the
principles of quantum mechanics it's
interesting to compare the human
perception of color to the perception of
sound our perception of sound in one way
is much richer when you have two pure
tones together like a C and a G a simple
chord that's a that's a v if you hear
that you can hear the separate tones
even though they're played together and
you hear a chord you can also sense the
separate tones and if one is louder than
the other you can you can continuously
judge how their their relative intensity
whereas with colors if you mix two
different if you have two different
colors say spectral green and spectral
red and mix them what you see is not a
chord where you where you can see the
distinct identities preserved but rather
an intermediate color in fact you'll see
something like that looks like yellow
the perception of color sort of throws
away
the detailed resolution a detailed
accounting of the different kinds of
underlying tones different kinds of pure
pure frequencies or pure colors that are
underlying the perception our perception
of that kind of mixture is
indistinguishable from our deception of
a pure spectral yellow such as you'd see
in a rainbow it's as if in music when
you play 2 C and a G together instead of
hearing a chord you just heard the note
e and in to meet the intermediate note
on the other hand visual information is
much richer in conveying the spatial
structure of things we get a detailed
image where a sound gives much poorer
spatial resolution and there are good
physical reasons for those things sound
waves are relatively slow relatively
slowly so that mechanical vibrations
inside our ear and electrical processes
inside our brain can keep up with them
and so we can keep that kind of time
structure we can keep track of it that's
why we do a good job with chords whereas
the oscillations in electromagnetic
radiation are very very fast much faster
than any mechanical system can keep up
with or then our nerve firings can keep
up with so the way we process that is
quite different that's an all-or-none
process where photons get absorbed and
trigger changes in the structure of
proteins and we have three kinds of
proteins in three different kinds of
cone cells that give us three kinds of
average responses and that's why you can
synthesize any perceived color with just
three